And now it's the old scout master.
Two scout hats went out for a hike.
Hats going out for a hike, that's right.
One got worn out and the other went on ahead.
Yeah, well, you come up with a better one, okay?
Hey, this is podcast 371..
Well, welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
So let's take a look in the long, neglected mailbag.
Here's some things that have come over the transom. in the past week
Had an email from Scott Day, who is the scout master of troop 311 in Springfield, Ohio,
who wrote in to say: I love your podcast.
I'm only two years of being a scout master.
Your podcasts have really helped
And I'm waiting for a t-shirt that says: don't fix that.
Well, thanks Scott.
Yeah, the don't fix that t-shirt.
I think I mentioned that in an attempt at humor several podcasts back.
I'll tell you what: grab one of your old t-shirts and a Sharpie.
There you go, pal,
You got one.
Don't wait on me.
You could wait on me for a long time for that.
But thanks, Scott for getting in touch.
Steven Moshka is the scout master of troop 43 in Appalachian, New York,
And he run in to say: I recently became the scout master for my son's new troop.
as he and I crossed over from Cub Scouts,
I took the plunge into the volcano immediately
and traded my Cub Master shirt for a Scout Master shirt.
I want to say thank you for all the great advice you've given out
through the podcast and the blog.
Having listened to all of the episodes now
and having read a great deal of the blog,
I feel confident in my ability as a scouter.
Of course I feel a little sorry for the other scouts
who have to deal with my excitement and energy to make things even better.
Thank you for all you've done for scouts like me.
Keep up the great work.
Well, thank you, Steven.
It's always good to hear that people find what we're doing here useful.
Craig Snodgrass is from Troop 1 in Altadena, California,
where he is the scout master.
Craig just checked in to kind of send me a report
about the way that their troop is incorporating the quarterly troop plan.
I've talked about that in a past podcast and a blog post
and I'll refer to those in the podcast notes.
But anyway, Craig wrote to say this:
I've been so happy with your 8-Part Fundamental Series
that I've shared it widely with others.
I've listened to each of the 8 podcasts at least twice
and found new insights and understanding. each time.
They're a masterpiece.
Well, thank you, Craig.
I'm humbled.
Our parents love having a quarterly parents meeting.
We've always had quarterly course of honor
and we had the intention of holding some kind of parents meeting
but never quite got around to it.
So having it just before the quarterly court of honor
has worked out perfectly for us.
Our Petroleum Leaders Council adopted the three month terms
for positions of responsibility you described in the quarterly plan.
We continue to make the change to quarterly planning
with a Petroleum Leaders Council
meaning devoted to that every three months,
And this avoids having the annual planning marathon
wrapped. everybody a little burned out
And we're in various stages of adopting the idea
of the three month permission slip and payments.
But I just want to check in and let you know
that, as a Scout Master, I'm really buying in
and it's all appearing to work. so far, so good.
Well, thanks, Craig.
I'm glad that that's working out for you.
As I said, I'll reference the material about that plan
in the podcast notes.
Take a look at it
And if you've been working with that,
if you've been adapting that approach for your troop,
I'd like to hear how it's working.
Well. the remainder of the podcast,
I'm going to share some answers to email questions
I have recently received.
So let's get started. shall we,
Stepping to my forest,
Feel the magic in the air?
I know that you're not evil.
I know deep down you care.
I cannot help but wonder
Why you do the things you do.
I hope you will remember
That it's applied it to,
Cause I am a Sasquatch
And I live among the trees
And I am proud to be a Sasquatch.
I live in peace and harmony,
In harmony.
Tim Nelson is with Cub Scout Pack 352
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
And Tim wrote in to say:
I'm the den leader of ten bears
soon to be weeblos.
Well, I want to introduce the patrol method to my den.
Do you think this is a good idea?
And should I have the scouts divide themselves into patrols,
Or should I divide them up?
Maybe initially ask who wants to be a patrol leader?
Well, Tim, some 30..
Well, it's more than 30 years ago now.
I had 18, count them 18- weeblos in my den.
Thankfully, this was before the second year of weeblos was instituted
And I was much younger. so I survived,
As did almost all of the 18 weeblos,
And I think, yes, definitely introduce the patrol method to your weeblos.
But remember, you've been applying the patrol method as a den.
You've just been the leader.
So what you're really introducing to them is a little more autonomy
and some responsibility for themselves and some decision making.
So they will know exactly how a patrol works
because you've been employing those methods as a den leader
and they employ a lot of things in the patrol method
all the time outside of scouts.
They just don't know that that's what they're doing.
So when you approach this, I would suggest maybe you think
of how you would coach a team of this age of young people in basketball.
Would you get them into the gym and explain everything about a layup
in detail as they sat on the bench listening attentively?
Or would you demonstrate a layup and then give them the ball
so they could get at it right away?
I'm going to guess you'd want them trying it out as soon as possible
And I would use the same approach in introducing them to the idea
of expanded independence and decision making
and responsibility. so far as patrols are concerned,
Don't explain it to them so much as show them how it works.
Give them a simple 10-minute game or tasks to play
or work on as a patrol. divide them up,
point patrol leaders. let them at it.
Once they've gone through the evolution of the game or tasks,
do a two minute.
When I say two minute, I'm talking literally two minutes.
Use your watch.
Do a two minute after action little session
where you ask them how it works.
Listen to their replies.
Don't offer a whole lot in the way of advice.
Just listen to what they have to say.
Ask them more questions about how they think it could work better.
Let them come up with those ideas on their own
And then try it again.
Now, sticking with the whole basketball analogy
now, would you have your brand new team play a league game
the first time that they were out together?
Think about that one.
Would you explain things about the game
and show them the rule book
and then throw them out to the court with the other team?
I know
I mean the answer is obvious. right
The same with patrols.
Don't make a big deal out of establishing permanent,
everlasting patrols
and trying to explain every little detail about it
before you start.
In other words, don't take your den
and just push them off into the deep end
and say: okay, now you're in patrols, have a good time.
Try the approach that I explain,
You know. just set them up in two different groups,
appoint a leader, give them a game or a task
That's going to last a few minutes,
Then ask them some questions afterwards
and take your time with it.
Go slow,
Don't attempt to explain everything.
Let them figure it out a little bit at a time.
You'll see some positive things happening
and some negative things.
I would do your best to ignore the negative things
and follow all over yourself about the positive things.
Every time you praise one of the positive things
that you see happening,
apply a point of the scout law
to define the positive thing you have seen.
An immutable rule of scouting at this age
and really at all ages,
is that you'll perpetuate what you pay attention to.
Make a big deal out of negative behavior,
and it will be repeated.
but deal with it quickly and quietly,
and it will be less likely to recur.
Make a big deal out of positive behavior,
and it too will be repeated.
I would say that in my experience,
most Weeblows den leaders
overestimate the abilities of their scouts,
at least a little too much.
They go a little too far
with the sophistication of activities
and, like most adults,
they talk way too much.
You have to have some game, to be
a good Weeblows den leader
and your challenge is leading them
through a very active hour
of time every week
where you talk or stop the action
as little as possible.
That should be your goal,
And one of the things that's really on your side,
as I said,
is they already know how this works,
even though they don't know that. they know
and they'll catch on very quickly.
Don't make it a system,
Make it a method.
I've pointed this out a few times recently.
talking about the system and the method,
Don't worry about how the patrols are made up
and don't get overzealous
about those,
about the systemic and administrative things.
Look at how the scouts are behaving
and how they're working together.
Observe a lot,
Listen a lot.
You'll see who works well together
and who doesn't.
and you know,
if you've already been with these guys for a year,
you got a pretty good idea of that. now
stay away from having them
make the choices of who's going to be
and what patrol now,
because there's just a whole lot of baggage
that goes with that,
especially at this age.
and you know-
and I need to qualify
that advice by saying
not every group is the same.
So you know, they may very well be able
to form their own patrols equitably
and make those good choices,
but I don't know.
I would probably recommend that you set it up
and appoint the patrol leader
for a meeting at a time
and then, you know,
switch things up,
try various combinations
and talk with your scouts about it a lot.
what you want in the end
is weeblows who understand how patrol works
and their responsibility
in making it work.
they'll get some things right away.
some things will be small,
incremental changes over the next couple of years.
and remember,
your position is called
weeblows den leader
for a reason.
scouts this age are not quite ready
to make complex leadership decisions
and lead each other
in a very sophisticated manner.
most of them-
and that's your job for now.
as their abilities develop over the next couple of years,
you'll respond
by giving them more responsibility
for leading themselves,
but you're the leader for now.
you direct and you decide.
encourage them to think for themselves
and discover things for themselves,
because they catch on very quickly that way.
you might want to study the Socratic method
and learn how to apply that really well.
when you do this,
they'll be pretty sure everything they learned
was simply something they discovered on their own.
weeblows is challenging.
it's great fun.
enjoy the moment.
don't be too obsessed
with preparing them for scouts
and don't treat the experiences junior boy scouts.
just go out
and do the things that weeblows do
and have a blast.
the next few years are going to fly by.
don't miss a minute.
the sender of the next email
has requested that they remain anonymous
and, honoring that request,
I will tell you that they wrote in
saying thanks for podcast 370 on older scouts.
seeing that the older scouts in our troop
were not as active or integrated into
having responsibilities as I would have liked,
I spoke with our committee
and the upshot is that we formed a subcommittee of adults
and I conducted a survey of older scouts.
what I found was that when I talked to the adults involved,
they wanted to up the ante
and design fun, interesting programs for the older scouts.
the older scouts expressed their willingness
to help with younger scouts as long as they
knew the game plan for the troop meeting
and how they fit into it.
they also talked about being respected
and feeling valued
and they said that they may or may not
participate in special older scout programs or events.
so after all that actually
not a whole lot changed.
the committee didn't have much of a response to my findings.
the scout master seemed to be kind of annoyed
by what I had to say
and in the end not much changed.
the adult volunteers basically ignored the problem
and the older scouts-
if and when they show up,
they sit at their own table talking
while the adults do stuff
most of the older scouts aren't going to participate in. anyway,
I'm a little frustrated.
I'm a trained, experienced leader.
I'm older than most of the adult volunteers,
I have a lot of energy,
but I find that my experience and training don't seem to matter
in your experience to younger adult volunteers
just kind of follow their nose
and do what they want, while older guys
with some knowledge like us becoming relevant.
well, there's a number of issues to deal with there.
first, let's say this:
you aren't irrelevant.
you have a lot of valuable experience.
you have a lot of valuable skill.
if anybody understands that,
you'll be helpful.
but these younger volunteers-
and we're talking people in their 30s and 40s-
they aren't going to ask for help
if they don't know that they need it.
and when you go and offer help
that they don't think that they need,
they may get a little aggravated with you.
as far as the older scout thing goes.
I can't tell you how many older scout problem solving sessions
I've been part of over 30 years.
each has played out as if the participants
were reading from the same script.
the same problems are expressed,
the same solutions are found
and the same results are gained,
which are at best mediocre to tepid.
you know, somebody discovers that older scouts
are a little disengaged
and all that interested as they were
when they were younger and then they
invent new programs for them
and the new programs are short lived
and not really well received.
and then we kind of go back
and begin that process
over and over again
and I talked a little bit more specifically about that
in last weeks podcast
as far as the
attitude of younger volunteers
towards older volunteers
and whether younger volunteers
really kind of get the program
or see the problems that you might see.
well, I think
some of the main difficulties with this
are kind of baked into the BSA structure
and expectations of-
oh, I don't know, I guess you could call it
culture. now, I alluded to this
in last weeks podcast.
I didn't go on about it because honestly,
these things aren't going to change
and I kind of feel like I'm beating a dead horse.
so these things I
talk up to being a price of doing business
in our organization.
it's just something we have to work with.
and what I mean specifically is
because we have packs and troops and crews
as separate units
and we expect volunteers to move along
with their children. if you look at it,
what happens in Cub Scouts? there are very few Cub Scouts
who have more than 3 or 4 years tenure,
and packs don't have any
institutional mammary.
they don't have the calming influence of an older, experienced
scouter being involved.
when one group of volunteers
moves on from a Cub Scout pack
into a Boy Scout troop,
the Cub Scout wheel gets reinvented locally-
what every 5 or so years.
so the new volunteers who come into Cub Scouting
reinvent things drawing on their
professional and family experiences
and you have a Cub Scout program
that's not really running along Scouting lines.
and when they
leave the Cub pack after having done that
for a few years, they take those same practices
into a Scout troop
and then you have a Scout troop that
is not really running along the lines
that Scouting is supposed to work.
so when Cub Scout
volunteers move into a Scout troop
and you know they will matriculate
and slowly take over,
they'll apply a lot of the things they invented in Cub.
this works for Scouts pretty well until
they're about 13 or 14,
and then those older Scouts generally
seek greener pastures somewhere else.
now you'd hope that having
required volunteer training would
intervene, but it doesn't, because
we fragmented that training
and it lacks mentoring or consistency.
most training sessions
are kind of heavy on
inoculating the BSA against liability claims.
they're very heavy on the logistics
of management and organizational
imperatives and something called
program delivery, whatever that is,
and little training time is devoted to
actually understanding the unique
transformative process of Scouting itself.
so the training
isn't really going to scratch that itch.
it's not going to get at that problem.
we don't have a way of qualifying volunteers
for their roles, we don't have any oversight,
we don't have a mentoring process or ongoing
evaluation of their performance,
and without examining any of those things
and why we are doing what we're doing,
there's not a whole lot of chance
that things are going to change.
so it kind of gets perpetuated
and our organizational bad habits
become hallowed traditions
and hallowed traditions become storied legends.
understanding and actually working with young people
becomes something of kind of secondary
importance because we've got all this cool
stuff we can do. so
in the end, what you attempted to do
was laudable, but I could predict
it wasn't going to work, for a couple of reasons.
first of all, you were up against
the culture that I just explained, right?
the second is is there's no use
in asking adults what they think will
remedy the situation with older Scouts,
because the few adults
who actually recognize the problem
don't know how to fix it. I mean, it stands
to reason, doesn't it? if they knew how
to fix the situation, they would.
there's also no reason to ask Scouts
what they want, because they don't need
to tell us what they want. we already know,
and so do they, kind of,
even if they can't figure it out,
because we know what they want. it's called Scouting.
that's why they're there. unfortunately, what's
happening at the meeting that they're at
is probably not Scouting.
back to my tired old basketball analogy.
if you show up at the door of the gym to play basketball,
I really don't need to ask you
what you want to do next
or if maybe you'd rather play football instead.
no, all I need to do
is unlock the gym and toss you the basketball
and you go ahead
and the game begins. same thing goes with Scouting.
if you're showing up at a Scout meeting.
what do you want?
do you want somebody to ask you what you want
or suggest that maybe there are other cool things
that you could know? you want to do the Scouting
game, so let's go.
the other reason that the approach that you took
probably wasn't going to work
is- this is a problem that the Scouts
didn't really care to solve.
they had figured out how to hang out
with their friends and probably do you know
some advancement work now and again,
and they calculated the level of attention
they had to pay to what adults were doing around them,
and
they paid not one penny more.
right,
because they're great efficiency experts.
they found a table.
they see the adults are doing things that the older Scouts
ought to be doing and they figure that they're free
to hang out and just shoot the breeze around their
special older Scout table.
now would they enjoy actually doing some Scouting?
you bet they would, but the adults are probably using
all the oxygen that would light a fire
under those older Scouts.
they're oblivious to this or they just figured that
that's how things work, because, after all,
when we joined the troop
a couple of years ago, wasn't that the way
the older Scouts acted then
now, even if you could convince these volunteers
to give things up to
work with the older Scouts and give them more
responsibility, the resulting chaos that
initially accompanies that
would probably be so disturbing I doubt
they would stick with it. and that's pretty cynical,
isn't it? but I think
you know it's real. it's been my experience
because we don't really have
a good way of bringing them in as volunteers
and we don't have a way of showing it to them.
I don't think too
many Scouters get to see the real
potential of Scouting. the BSA
tells them both directly and indirectly.
it's a program
of activities presented by adults to youth
with measurable outcomes,
which is almost the polar opposite
of what Scouting actually is.
Scouting is this chaotic
yet kind of controlled process.
it's kind of a controlled burn.
you know
where you want to keep that field open.
so there's a controlled burn every five or six years.
it's a little chaotic, right, it's a little.
oh, you know that might
get out of control. it's
like Baden Powell said: it's a jolly
game. it shapes the character
of young people experientially.
it's not an orderly or adult mediated.
in fact, when Scouting is
happening, adults play a very
tangential role in the whole process.
it's a transformative
progression of experience for our young
people to learn to
do for themselves and to
become good, solid
people of good character.
so it's not about being irrelevant,
or that no one is interested,
or experience and training don't seem to matter.
it's just that if
you see a problem and you
say, hey, I think this is a problem, and everybody
else says, meh, you know, I don't see it
as being a big problem, well,
you wouldn't want to spin your wheels there
and the other. the other thing is
is to is. you know there's
a certain joy in figuring
out how all this works.
I spent 30 years figuring out
by the seat of my pants on the fly
how Scouting works. you know,
I took the training. I got some out of that.
I read, I got some things out of that.
I talked with people who I respected in Scouting.
I got some out of that. but you know,
you figure things out on the fly,
you learn the hard way and you eventually
get better at being a Scouter, and that's
almost three quarters of the fun
of being part of it. anyway,
if you listen this far,
you're in for a big treat
or you're about to be traumatized.
you can.
you can choose which one,
because after last week's podcast
about older Scouts there was a very brief
Facebook exchange.
Dave Klein asked me to clarify the idea
of having a Venture Patrol
or crew as a change of
status for our older Scouts and what I explained
in last week's podcast-
that when our Scouts
enter into high school
we sign them up to be members of
our Venture Crew. we have a chartered
Venture Crew and Dave asked
whether or not they changed to wearing
the Venturing Uniform
at that time. my answer
is no. we discussed it
but nobody seemed to be
very interested in doing that.
and then somebody very
helpfully clarified that
there are Venture Crews and Venture Patrols
and you know
the whole thing
kind of put a B in my bonnet. so the treat
for you, if you've listened thus far,
or the way you are about to be traumatized,
is a little bit of a rant
or a diatribe or a
soapbox session about
my opinion,
my read of
the present situation. so
if you would rather skip this,
please do
so. we've been discussing
the whole subject of working with older Scouts
and some years ago,
when it was clear to me that
we needed to have a distinct
change in status for our older Scouts
that would help them kind of wrap their heads
around what was going on
and would give them a
line of demarcation that
they could say that they were separate
from the younger Scouts, which, counter
intuitively, makes them more likely to
help the younger Scouts.
I looked at the idea of having a Venture
Patrol and I guess we kind of had a Venture
Patrol for a little while and then
you know, we have had an annual
high adventure trip every single
year for the past 14 years
and we wanted to
be able to offer that experience to
girls in our community.
so we established a Venture Crew
and we have had several girls come along
on those trips and it's been great.
but establishing a Venture Crew
and then running the Venture Crew
is kind of problematic
because of the way the whole thing
is set up. and the whole thing is set up
the way that it is
because
when the Venturing Program was established,
based on some of the ideas from the Explorer Program,
the idea was to have
young women involved. but those
young women couldn't
earn the same awards
that the older boys
and a scout troop could earn. so there had to
be a very bright line between
who was a Venturer
and who was a scout, which means
a separate unit, a separate committee,
a whole other approach to positions of
responsibility and everything like that, and if you sit
and look at it it's kind of
confusing. Now I'm not trying to cast
shade on anybody who has a successful
Venturing Program. Good for
you, more power to you,
go get them. What
my problem is is that
when somebody charters a Venture Crew
it is perceived as being in
competition for the attention of older
scouts who are part of a scout troop,
and scout masters are famously
skeptical about Venture Crews.
they kind of feel like in
vase on their turf and
Venture Crew volunteers
feel kind of put aside by
scout troops and it's
kind of a mess that you really wish
didn't exist. and I see
a similar mess coming
in the way that the BSA is welcoming
girls into membership
in scout troops in February
of next year, because the only way that you
can have girls involved is to charter
a girls troop
alongside of
the boys troop. and yes, I've read
through all the announcements and now
we're setting up another
administrative division
with having girls troops and it's going
to cause a fair amount
of needless trouble
and needless agita for a lot of
volunteers and for girls
and for boys. if
it is the opinion of your unit.
the approach of having boys
and girls in fully separate
units is a good
approach, I think you know. fine,
go ahead and do that. personally,
I feel it's a very bad message
to send to boys and to girls to keep
them separated that way.
but you know what, if that's
the way that you want to serve the young people
in your community, I'm not going to
complain about it. The thing that
I get kind of chapped about
is the idea that there is no
fully coed alternative,
and when I mean fully coed
I mean that you have a scout
troop with scouts in it, and
whether they are boys or whether
they are girls is kind of immaterial.
they're scouts and they just work
in a scout troop. so you have boys
and girls in patrols, you have boys
and girls in the troop and in
the patrol leaders council,
no big deal. and I know
that that works, and it works very well
because the vast majority
of scouting organizations
in the rest of the world
apply the fully coed model
just like that. Now, I don't think that
should be forced on you. if that's not something
that you want to do- and you do have
the option- you can just ignore
the idea that girls are allowed to join
now and keep your troop. all boys,
it's fine, that's an option.
what I'm upset about is there's no fully coed
option for those of us who see
that as the way that
scouting could best serve the young people
in our community. If this seems
disjointed from
the discussion that we've been having
about older scouts, it's not
because the precedent
for this idea of creating
further administrative divisions
when all's we want to do
is serve the young people in our community
with a scouting program
is frustrating, because we've seen how it works
in venturing and it doesn't work very well.
what if you go to the
doors of your meeting place and open them
and say to your community at large:
any young person
who wants to have a scouting experience is welcome here.
regardless of their gender,
regardless of their sexual orientation,
regardless of their religious
beliefs, we can all be
scouts together. BSA,
over the past 5 or 10 years you have made
some big strides
in making us able to do that,
but this one, where we're going to
bring girls in and bring them
into a separate unit, that
is kind of taking
two steps forward and
three steps back, and I am
told that a lot of people will just kind of ignore it
and have a fully co-ed program anyway.
but what kind of a message does it send
to our scouts, when we have clearly defined
policies and procedures that we just
kind of fudge or ignore
or create
elaborate justifications
for ignoring or
going directly counter to
those things?
it's an uncomfortable feeling,
like the old preacher said. it kind of
feels like washing your feet with your socks
on.
hey, I'm going to stop
there. that's my diatribe,
that's my soapbox moment and you can get
in touch with me and we'll talk about it.
you know the idea that girls are
going to be a part of the BSA. that's settled business.
frankly, I'm just not interested
in arguing about that. we've already
done that. it's settled,
this is happening. but if you want to talk
about how it's going to happen, I'm happy
to get in touch with me. I really
do enjoy your emails, I enjoy talking
with you and I'm going to tell you how to do that
in just a moment.
well, thank you so much for listening to
this 371st
edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
you're going to find a whole
load of articles
and editions of the scout master
podcast at scoutmaster
cgcom.
go on over there.
you can subscribe to receive updates to the
blog and the podcast by email.
you can join us on social media, at facebook
and twitter, and if none
of that works for you, just fire
me off a good old fashioned email
at Clark at scoutmaster
cgcom:
K-R-K-E
at
scoutmastercgcom.
I want to say thank you
to all the people who join in to
make the scout master podcast
and blog possible.
we have patrons, we have backers.
you can join them by going to
scoutmastercgcom
and following links there at the top of every page on the website.
I also want to mention I am not
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any scouting organization for that matter.
I am just trying to lend a hand
to my fellow scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun here, he is
our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.